What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are experimenting
with a higher net.
We have three different set-ups.
Let's start with the first one!
It was a roller on this table!
That's a good one.
Good one!
What was that?
It almost worked out.
We rehearsed that like 10 times but it still didn't work.
You should always be expecting
that I do something weird like that!
And guys we have a lot of crazy
videos coming out
so don't forget to hit subscribe
so you don't miss out!
No! It was a broken ball!
That was a good one.
It was a good point!
It's so weird because I can't see
you at all!
That would have been an interesting one!
Under the net.
Yeah we had some
pretty interesting table set ups today!
Hope you guys enjoyed this video!
Yeah and remember to subscribe our channel here
And watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!